je suis ça va mon chéri dans la superbe
je trouve beau est-ce que je me trouve
beau si jamais je trouve beau parce que
je sais pourquoi je te pose cette
question parce qu'on va faire un petit
jeu dans un instant on va tester notre
notre beauté une société a créé une
application qui nous permet de savoir si
on est beau ou pas et elle donne une
note sur 5 ans mais là je l'observais
par exemple regarder les notes de cette
application donne à certaines stars
regardez par exemple on à emmanuel
macron il à 3,8 sur sa red hat et les
plus tombeaux royaux pas à emilie
rattache au ski voilà elle a incarné la
femme sur cinq ans à 4 5 sur 5
les délais se moque t on sanctionne
ménard
joey starr on attendait d'eux deux
années pour ma faute si je m'attendais à
son mari ça dépend de la photo ici s'il
n'arrivait à peu près olala ce qui
dégoûte pas possible scolaire ars
comment parler vraiment peut rien faire
mais c'est vrai qu'on peut rien faire
julien ce que vous trouvez moi je me
donne je pense que l'application va me
donner de huit noms déjà trois buts mini
série voilà on a rentré tous les visages
tous les chroniqueurs
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas obtenu dégueulasse comme on
la comprend pas il a mis un blouson
c'est vrai on est qui va pas lui même
club
[Applaudissements]
le gain de temps que oui messieurs
et cela parce que vous trouvez vous pas
dit oui c'est pas moi de le dire mais je
me dit non oui je le bats globalement
oui et je profite de ces petites
secondes que vous me donnez pour
remercier les fans notamment de
l'étranger d'autres continents qui vont
sauter mon anniversaire c'est un coup de
chine afrique asie oui oui par les
incontinences isabelle c'est pas pareil
[Applaudissements]
senna le classement de la 11e à la
personne numéro un si l'un c'est une
application ça ne veut rien dire
c'est selon les traits tout ça moi ça me
fait de la peine pour la personne en
dernière position et c'est pas du tout
méritée paul shin proches comme c'est
pas chez moi c'est ma fille c'est moi
c'est une vraie merveille
alors je vous le dis et je pense qu'ils
ont mal que la plus complète possible il
ne rit pas
allez on passe vite sur la vente au
numéro 10 au gil cgc avec 2003 photo n
est pas les manières il était magnifique
je suis très contente tout ça c'est de
très bonnes notes ah oui je te raconte
en moi arrêtez arrêtez de dire vous êtes
magnifique à tout le monde en neuvième
position
c'est jean michel berrit les palaces il
évoque sa vie
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est jean-michel je vous jure c'est
jean michel vous avez 2,4 était superbe
6e position huitième position de l'api
celui qui est le huitième plus beau
gainey et bien c'est oit julien courbet
sérieux avec 2,6 je veux dire le
septième essai bouder
[Applaudissements]
c
hélas hélas la photo elle ne vous met
pas dans les maisons en sixième position
pas mal avec 2,8 oui maxime gagnon
[Applaudissements]
ok position je suis en cinquième
position avec 2 les belges arrivé à
pékin les garçons c'est la position et
là je vous le dis on fait un bon niveau
des notes
ah ouais enfin bon au niveau des notes
en quatrième position c'est géraldine a
très bien avec 3,6
en troisième position
elle m'a botté par dont tu ne m'as
merveille tpo sérieux wendel est en tête
je vais donner je vous demander de venir
tous les deux comme israël veut tenir
par la main les deux petits ponts avec
une note de 4 bien que le cac ouvre la
énorme sur sa jeunesse et ses manies
sinon machel est au dessus des milleirs
h mcl automation il est au dessus de
gagner sachez que le deuxième à une note
de 4,2 aussi quand même un pas mal hein
on sera le grand gagnant c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]